one ignition and liftoff of Columbia and
the first dedicated medical research
flight the year was 1991 it was a time
of great change in January a coalition
of forces led by the United States
commenced Operation Desert Storm in Iraq
beginning the invasion with aerial
bombardments and long-range artillery in
June the space shuttle Columbia carried
the life sciences one module into orbit
to study the effects of spaceflight on
the human body that same year the first
public web servers were made available
marking the beginning of the Internet as
we know it today and as the Year came to
a close eleven former Soviet Union
Republic's established the Commonwealth
of Independent States effectively
dissolving the USSR and marking the end
of Mikhail Gorbachev's presidency but
nestled between these momentous events
was the release of a new video game it
was called civilization and in many ways
this was a game about change a game
about science culture a game about
nations their rise and fall in the
course of human history its box art read
build an empire to stand the test of
time now 25 years and eight games later
the Civilization series has done just
that
the world is so interconnected right now
I think any game that sort of plays on
the unique characteristics and cultural
strengths of all the different peoples
of the world is just perfect for this
day and age for the uninitiated the
Forex strategy genre can be daunting
it's known for its complexity and depth
in the blend of macro and micro
management that comes with building a
digital Empire but despite the learning
curve civilization has without a doubt
stood the test of time it began under
microprose a studio formed by two
designers named Sid Meier and bill
steely who in 1996 would later found
Firaxis games and takes civilization
with them so when we got the opportunity
to visit for access in Hunt Valley
Maryland it was only natural that I
asked the creator's their side of the
story after a quarter of a century how
is civilization still going strong think
it's just one of those games it
resonates with people you know when you
think about Forex strategy games and
stuff of course it's one of the you know
prime examples of that genre
you know civilization the first one came
out in 1991 I think it ignited the
imaginations of a lot of players it was
kind of something that was a genre that
we hadn't really seen before could
obviously see that Civilization 3 was
you know total 2d animated sprites the
whole nine yards was a great snapshot of
the civilization of four was brand-new
to 3d and it showed a little bit and had
very earthy colors it was the at the
time was considered cutting-edge you
know because in Civilization four and
before is a very sort of macroeconomic
strategic game so in Civilization 5 we
changed that significantly brought it
about to be about tactical knowledge
about those small moves about you know
heroic efforts like somebody holding the
line on a hill somewhere and being able
to kind of bottleneck something so I
think that really changed the series in
a good way and brought the sort of
highlighted the tactics in a way that
wasn't really there before
as with any series as pervasive as
civilization it's not hard to see each
entry as a reflection of where video
games were at at the time but if each
sieve game leaves a legacy a unique
innovation it can pass on to its sequel
where does Civ 6 fit in the grand scheme
of things
can you talk about like the pressure of
picking up the mantle like the numbered
sieve game like where do you even go
from sieve five especially after its
expansions yeah I'm glad I'd was lead on
this I could not have done it and I
could not have I don't know how that guy
keeps the whole game in his head the
question is sort of how do we keep the
game design fresh and moving forward and
you know people will say well I've
already bought three copies of
civilization you know why do I need
another one it's definitely an
intimidating title to work on especially
you know when you start on it you're
like where can you know where can we go
from here you know that we're on the
sixth iteration you know what are we
gonna do a game about civilization it's
such a grand title and it is very
ambitious in a lot of ways we're trying
to represent even though it's like in
this sort of caricatured gamey way all
of human history there's been some
there's been some pretty crazy things
that humans have done throughout all of
human history there's also been a lot of
interesting things that they've done
through all of human history so there's
never going to be a shortage of ideas in
terms of game mechanics when you have a
foundation like what he made with
civilization he's got the basic things
we are starting with the city and you're
making some key decisions and you're
working without outward from there so
it's a very simple premise that can lead
to very in-depth engaging gameplay but
everything that happens between that
first city and when you win is the sky's
the limit you have history to fall back
on
the guy would put some four more in the
simulation side where there's a lot of a
lot of math going on behind the scenes a
lot of interesting stuff but it's more a
little bit more of a sandbox I think
where civilization 5 felt a little bit
more like a board game I think with
Civilization six we've kind of landed
right in the middle in an interesting
way we have a lot of simulation elements
while still having that really kind of
fun mechanical board game feel but we
wanted to look at things for
Civilization six in kind of a fresh way
in terms of the way people interact with
the game and the way that people can
look at what they've created and so I
think that's been you know the big win
with Civilization six is everything out
there on the map that you're looking at
is sort of your creation because the map
is really in a lot of ways the star of
civilization that's the part that's
random every time it's one of the the
biggest fuel sources for that procedural
storytelling
the scary part about this for us that's
always scary when you're always in game
but particularly for civilization sex is
we were really aggressive we wanted to
make the biggest sieve that we've ever
made out of the gate we didn't want our
players to think of anyway whoa they
held stuff back there waiting for the
expansions for it to be done we wanted
to release something big you know we
know we have something that's going to
be establishing you know a new phase for
the civilization franchise
well as if I want to be the cold hard
taskmaster that I am I would say my goal
is is to make people forget the previous
versions of civilization because this
will be the version of civilization we
always have fans that usually split in a
few camps because I'm a lot of them that
we've still got fans that love
civilization before we've got fans that
love civilization five we've got fans
that we hopefully love civilization six
but um hopefully if we've done our job
and we've done everything what we want
to do they're gonna be like now I don't
think I need to play those on there
anymore this is the one that I want to
play that would be the goal I think
that's the goal with each iteration is
to really make them so that this is
everything they could possibly want
that's how much work we put into this
that's the goal don't know if that will
happen but you know we can try
for access games is no stranger to lofty
goals the studio's made a name for
itself by creating games about the
entirety of human history and for access
hasn't just survived but flourished for
a quarter of a century
numerous designers have come and gone
branching off from that prolific studio
to craft their own projects and that's
what we're exploring in part 2 of this
series the wider effect the civilization
franchise has had on the entire strategy
genre from the games that set new
standards to the people with the talent
and drive to envision them no one knows
if civilization has another 25 years
ahead of it but as of now it's ripple
effects are all around us it is the
nature of humankind to push himself
toward the horizon
we test our limits
we face our fears we rise to the
challenge
and become something greater than
ourselves
you